what would you say are like one two
three absolute crucial questions that
people need to think about if they do
want to grow a significant business or
have more clarity on their purpose I
think you should be clear on what are
you leaving are you leaving because
you're trying to move away from
something or are you leaning into and
moving towards something some people
don't really understand that that
question is so important that's vital
you might be in a great job you might be
in a job where you don't enjoy the
environment you might be looking at the
revenues in that business and thinking I
am only getting X percent of those
revenues my commission isn't as strong
as it could be so I think before you get
into this you need to think about what
you're actually doing currently again to
sort of keep on that purpose and Mission
thing building a recruitment company
isn't very easy at all doing deals might
be easy short term it might be easy but
long-term building a recruitment company
is not very easy at all which is why a
lot of people don't do it take a good
hard look at yourself and think am I
running away from something or am I
leaning into something